être en danger les pompiers que les
citoyens merci
madame la présidente Madame la
Commissaire chers collègues merci aux
présidents de notre commission emploi
Dragos pis la rue d'avoir l'idée d'avoir
eu l'idée de mettre le sujet des
conditions de travail de nos pompiers à
l'ordre du jour alors nous le savons
c'est un métier exigeant en termes
d'exposition à des substances
dangereuses en termes de santé mentale
de santé physique et avec
malheureusement le changement climatique
de plus en plus d'interventions tous les
étés tous les ans et donc des dangers
accrus dans ce contexte nous attendons
de la Commission et du Conseil des
initiatives pour mieux protéger et
soutenir nos pompiers en Europe alors
quelles sont nos propositions des
standards européens nous l'avons dit
pour les équipements qui doivent être
modernisés et adaptés aux situations de
crise intense davantage d'échanges entre
les États membres en matière de
formation
on pourrait réfléchir au développement
d'un centre d'excellence européen dans
le domaine de la protection civile une
surveillance médicale adéquate accrue
avec un protocole de
décontamination puisque les pompiers
sont particulièrement exposés aux
substances dangereuses telles que le
plomb et l'amiante les textes sur
lesquels nous travaillons vont être
importants à cet effet susciter
davantage de vocation en améliorant leur
condition de travail et en promouvant
l'engagement volontaire en Europe et
enfin renforcer les capacités de la
réserve riskyu pour mieux lutter
ensemble contre les catastrophes